hey I'm back this is gonna be a very
short stream but I wanted to at least
get one in because I haven't been
streaming for a while
I think it's been at least a week maybe
even two weeks I'm in st. Louis right
now I was in Nashville a few days ago
the cago before that so very hectic
schedule I'm just gonna play some blitz
if people are watching you can challenge
me
you can answer or you can ask questions
and I'll try and answer them but for now
I'm going to join the weekly blitz arena
should make sure the stream is actually
working to put to twitch
you
looks to be live
waiting for a game to start
oh no I forgot I have blindfold turned
on because I was practicing a game with
my students okay the first game is gonna
be blindfold I don't know how this is
gonna go and he plays f4 and move one uh
let's play
let's play d6 / e 5 9 f 3 e 5 maybe if
you take second place 5
not the best opening to play in
blindfold but we'll see what happens
uh Oscars chair is nice though it
actually might be Jen's chair I forget
which person sits on which side plays
III
I can play g4
I apologize to the viewers who probably
don't know what's going on in this
position especially if you just joined
we have a very strange birds opening I'm
gonna take the pawn on e5 attacking this
knights after this game we'll switch
back to normal chess
but okay this is this is actually
looking like a fun position I'm going to
put the Bishop on d6
and it plays efore
don't know if that does too much it does
block my e-pawn though
such a strange position this is not the
position I would usually like in a
blindfold game but I guess I'll have to
deal with it
debating where to put my tonight let's
play Knight f6
at some point I might turn on the pieces
during the game if I if I struggle too
much but hopefully that won't happen I'm
just gonna develop like I have a decent
idea where the pieces are
ship III
I'll play h5 reinforces pawn on g4
he plays 93 okay so we're just
developing I've all my minor pieces
developed
like Knights on the outside bishops on
the inside he plays Bishop e2
let's go for the pond storm because why
not
it's gonna be hard to look at the chats
while playing blindfold so I apologize
but I'll look at the chat afterwards
I'll change back the board settings
afterwards as well I'm playing Knight 9
h5 going for more attack he might Castle
queenside though it's probably a good
move and I have to go for a Queen side
attack
you
Bishop g5 attacking my queen
Oh an attacking this Paulo knife to play
Bishop t6 or Bishop d6 to e7 goes back
to e3
hmm
I think you can play mighty for
let's see anything wrong with it
it's just difficult when all the pieces
are still on the board and things get
more complex I'm gonna tack on the
queenside with a five if you want to
actually know where the pieces are you
can observe me you can type in the
command leach s in the chat and you
should be able to observe me this is
unpleasant
I am losing track I just played a five
you played a 95 I take twice went upon
I don't understand
quint 85
maybe he's winning g4 but H is attacked
you
and my Knights still on d4 right
a to
wait why can't I take on a two
you have a 9 on b3
go back oh he played might be three okay
well now I can play a 5 or a 4
and now the night is almost trapped
where does a knight go
I guess he could wait I have a 9 on d4
still right but he could take on
but then I can take on any two
threatening meats
this is getting very complex
I'm so confused why can't I take the
pawn oh he took with bishop on d4
I can take with pawn and be three
please just resign I think I'm winning
but
if he knows I'm playing vine ville you
might play on
is resign
when I this is just a crushing position
I'm pretty sure this Bishop is hanging
and I'm about to take on a two and just
promotes
he plays a three it's probably decent
resistance
with pawn or did I take the bishop first
like with Queen on g4
we should take h5 once
I'm losing track before all the pieces
are
take on a three as I see one mating idea
queen better be on d2
he plays c3 but okay ones mate yes I won
I was losing track of the position but
that was exciting
let's actually go back turn on the
pieces and see what happened there
and hello to people in the chats sorry I
was ignoring you guys i just can't i
can't play blindfold and look at the
chat at the same time so hello red
samurai uh yeah i'm in i'm in the test
studio if you guys want a behind the
scenes shot uh why is this not working
my webcam not working
oh the the other webcam is on
okay let me go to video source
properties and then other one
what
I did not work
these
there we go okay little exposure is a
bit right but okay um if you guys want a
behind the scenes I'm actually in a
chair at maybe aa cert has sat in
there's a couch area I'm here because
I'm doing commentary for this event
going on for next what eight or nine
days so I'll be live on the st. Louis
Chess Club YouTube channel in a couple
hours I'm just doing a quick stream
because uh I mean what else to do
so uh yeah let's go back to or let's go
to analysis board let me go to
preferences
let me say hi to more people in the
chats ah cos hello oh no me pants good
to see you
Raj mattoon I don't think I've seen that
name before but welcome you Savage I'm
doing well
somebody very special in the chat
I'll have to go back and look uh but
yeah let's actually see that game
I don't usually play blindfold even
though it is a good exercise only time I
play blindfold is with my lower rated
students we play kind of just for
training games and then they have a
chance to beat me especially when I
blender or lose track of the position
but yeah this game I tried to be
creative in the opening I was just
inventing this maybe this is a real line
um I might have to do some research
given that it's been played before
methyl Eagle thanks for following and I
mean the idea is very clear just to play
g4 kick the night enough take before
night has to move Bishop take d6 for
example like blacks already threatening
made in three with Queen h4
so he played yeah he played III which
maybe as a standard move but I was happy
with the position
yeah I still had a good idea where all
the pieces were here but then things got
a bit weird
I was going for an eye tooth for and he
played Bishop g5 which I missed out to
play Bishop e7 he retreated I went for
Knight d4 and then I went for a five and
then for some reason I just forgot the
night was still on b3
and then okay he just lost a pawn here
for some reason
but he want it back and then I forgot
yeah I forgot I couldn't take money too
so I played a four and then he took with
Bishop and I took with pawn and that now
box just winning material because the
bishop is attacked and if I can take
this pawn all all promotes so he played
a three I took
I was attacking this bishop I didn't
even see how he's attacking that Bishop
I also have Bishop g5 ideas which I
didn't see okay so he took the knight
I honestly didn't realize there was a
knight on h5 that he captured I was just
going for mates and then thankfully
enough he allowed rook a long what can
you do here to survive
maybe Queenie one
gee five I wonder if I would have found
Bishop g5
now this might be uh this might actually
be forced mate the Queen has nowhere to
go forward I can't move forward and if
it moves off the diagonal then the ship
g5 is deadly
so is it just for us maybe best move is
Bishop take f7
Bishop take f7 is nice because then he's
oh he can't take on b3 because I play
Rick anyone mate so I would play king d
eights
and it still force meats
really turn on sock fish I would
probably guess it's like meeting I've
made in six
or not how does he survive Bishop take
f7
kingi it
Oh see take P three per galaxy take P 3
then I would just have to take H five
Oh work to gauge 5 is a cool line this
is hard to calculate queening one check
Bishop g5 even smoother okay that was a
fun game hello to more people in the
chat hello excise sparks hello Braden
hello Dora a noob more people hello
Jetta let me know where you guys are
from I'm in st. Louis right now I know
it's probably
like mostly us people maybe some Canada
people definitely at least one Canada
person and then maybe some European
night owls but okay let's maybe let's
play one more game I'll go back to the
tournament
the scheme won't be blindfold
polish living in an L what's an L is
that New Zealand Oh
new something
Chicago I'm from Chicago too
not late in Europe oh yeah it's still
early yes that's true I thought I
switched it back to blindfold where's my
okay I'm whites
I mean I would continue playing
blindfold but I want people to actually
watch this game so I don't know why it
updates
oh maybe I didn't actually change it
let's refresh the board there we go okay
now I'm happy
see the pieces see the beautiful London
f3
I think f3 is a the principled move
because then it's a Java line but up a
tempo and then like Knight c3
Bava usually has this position or a
position like this with black to move
but here it's White's move so that's
nice
h4 going for g4 he plays h5 ah maybe
I'll put the night on g3
and then I'll make his bishop move again
and I'll trade off the bishop
eventually I'll go for a four
Oh Netherlands aha but have no nuts
take on g6
and this guy is only 1400 and heba's
hurts me okay let's play Queen d3 I'm
gonna go after this weakness I think he
has to play King f7
he plays Queen c7 okay thank you very
much
what to do
take Annie for
my queen defends this night oh my Queens
almost trapped but I have Queen g5
and that's fortunate I want to play e5
next you might play nine eight seven and
then maybe I'll play e5
five looks
antonio morales has a question about
Knight c3 let me get back to that after
this game let's finish Bryan finish this
game as quickly as possible
go for the kill Castle queenside
and his pieces are not impressive
nothing's coordinated these two pieces
are stuck but an other night in brook
are also not impressive I kind of want
to just play 94 second night maybe f4 is
a better way to go
f4 f5 open the F file editor up to f1
or take a free rook they Gani six first
then take the rook
you
rooks on open vials have smiles I said
that during the broadcast yesterday it
is a is a great line for students
younger students don't play Queenie
hates me seven where's my mates
okay let's take on each five it's a free
pawn
and then maybe Knight f4 and I win
another rook
keep taking free stuff
okay rooks on open files have smiles
follow that rule well he wants to do
something I can't take on c6 because
then he mates me yes I have to trade
Queens
it's going to take longer to mate
without the Queen
heyyyyyy resigns okay let's see let's
see the question from Antonio Morales I
have a question about 293 suggestion on
the Sicilian the trap you have in the
video where black plays d5 to early is
nice but what if black plays a six
first the whole trick doesn't work is
that correct I think I know what uh what
he's referring to
also Thank You past pawn for the
comments ask 199 um yeah let's go to
some of the study where's my study
by the my studies opening preparation
I think this is a good collaborative
study Lucas
thanks for the hundred bits there a
message with that it's just bits thank
you for the bits d nation Ches good to
see you doing well
very busy this coming week is extremely
busy so I'm not sure how much time we'll
have to stream but we'll see I want to
make a new chapter
let's see it's Cillian bowline
okay so let's answer this question was
it from again Antonio uh yeah so Antonio
is referring to this line a really cool
line
for those of you who don't know I'll
just show it real quick where
it's a common idea for black in this
part of Bishop b5 Bishop c4 line they go
for the media d5
I'm select she let's look how this works
for uh for whites after d5
BOC is actually falling into the trap
after I take d5e take d5 there's a
beautiful continuation for whites and
anyone who's watched this video on
YouTube has probably seen it but the
amazing move here is might take d5
sacking a piece and after Knight takes
e5 Knight takes e4 pawn to d4
it looks like White's just down a piece
seems like blacks doing okay but then
white has overwhelming common
compensation with Queen h5 and black
actually is gonna collapse here and
white is either winning back enough
material and will be up material or
white will get like a crushing attack so
I guess I should go further and show
kind of the keyline like why this
actually works cuz after Bishop e6 White
has rook e1 with the threat of both rook
take you 6 and Bishop take d5 so the
best try for black perhaps is something
like 9 f4 but then very simply there's
Bishop b5 forcing keen e7 and light
winds back the piece with a great
position and actually had this in a
tournament game actually had this in an
alley chess game recently I believe I
showed the tournament game in the
YouTube video but the Lea chess game
let's switch databases
yeah the Li chess game actually there's
been a good number of games from this
position after a king take King to f7
the best move or why it is to take on e6
I don't know why my game is not showing
up maybe it was too recent
pretty sure I had this and then after
this Queenie four check and okay White
has rushing attack we can turn on stock
fish just to verify but +4 so anyway I
think it's important to understand that
and then we'll go to Antonia's question
with the difference of black playing a6
first
and after a six yeah it's a stronger
move for black it's probably the best
move where black is immediately
threatening the threatening to trap the
bishop with b5 I think the best move
here is to play d3 and now if we imagine
black plays d5 the inclusion of a 63
actually helps black because if we look
at the same line here here here here
here here
Bishop e6 wait why am I getting confused
brookey one
I know there's a reason this doesn't
work
for a different movement Bishop e6
as neither four is actually prevented
here
take take take take queen h5 and whites
scoring very well but I thought there
was a problem with this line
a 6:45
as a threat of b5
well why is Bishop B check Bishop b5
check necessary I'm just gonna get a
quick answer and turn on stock fish is
this still a good line for whites
it is why
maybe it's inclusion of b5
pick take now this is a very good line
for white what's the question
rap you have in the video of black plays
d5 to early
I honestly thought this this line didn't
work for whites but it's been a while
since I looked at it
oh maybe the why I'm getting confused is
that if we look at maybe the other
option for white to play a fort
preventing b5 then the line doesn't work
because of the the reason that Antonio
mentioned in this line
a-after queen h5 Bishop e6 rook e1
neither four is actually saving black I
believe right
yeah because rooked a key six might take
you six is queenie seven and
um an inclusion of a for a for a 6/8 for
helps black because it does prevent
Bishop b5 so I guess it's a small nuance
which is important to recognize when
delving into like these tactical lines
so that's why probably if you run into
this line just play d3
a 63 and the trap still exists
assuming stockfish is correct
um now a common way for Bach to play
here is not to play d5 but to play b5
and then we could get some position like
this where I can often take on b3 played
Bishop d7 and at some more strategic
fights rather than position opening up
very early but it's playable for whites
I enjoy playing the sin blitz as White's
plan is uh is usually pretty direct I'll
mention one maneuver or white plays in
early like night g1 to f3 and there is
some game like high level game like
between suit to super jeans as either
Anand gelfand or morozova ch maybe
morozova CH playing this is white and
like this my G 1 2 F 3 maneuver is
actually a very useful thing to employ
in the middle game
um so
I'm telling you Morales I don't know if
I answered his question what to play
against a six I mean are you asking
about a six line move to
as a six on move to is a whole different
line
I don't think I'll have time to go over
super in-depth but I can give you just a
quick recommendation re KP yes this is a
Grand Prix attack except I like to call
it Knight c3 Sicilian because the grand
prix attack is kind of kind of
identified with this move f4 and Knight
f3 and white doesn't always go for that
depending what black plays
um this is not though Kelly no Kelly is
uh is 9 f3
followed by a six and it's a big
difference because White has a move like
c3 or c4 with the knight on c3 a6 makes
a bit more sense for black because black
goes for the early b5
so let me just show one more cruel kind
of game just to give people some
inspiration because I actually didn't go
over a line that I wanted to in the
video will add a new chapter it will say
Knight c3 Cillian what to play against
do a six
actually let's make this title more
exciting out to crush
do a six okay this will be really quick
c4 c5 Knight c3 a6 I recommend playing
f4 here actually wait a minute
actually don't know if the move order
matters at some point white will play f4
or g3 ship G 2 and D 3 let's say g3 is
first
maybe slightly more flexible
okay so b5
and we'll just see that one of the most
popular lines for black after there
should be seven now I can play D 3 e six
and now have four and if we know this
the most common move for black is to
play d5 and the turn off opening book
for the time being so let's say black
plays b5 or d5 this is a position you're
aiming for if you're playing against
this to a six line if you see this
position you should get excited because
there's a very rare move here for white
and I'm gonna turn the opening book back
on because I'm just curious where this
move Falls yeah this move is not not
within the top five
this move is actually the six most
popular move which is plum at five and I
think it's the strongest move and it's
very hard for blacks to deal with if
blacks not prepared I had a game in this
I was white
hmm anyway let me show the kind of the
two main lines normally black has to
play d4 I don't think there's a another
reasonable move because if black plays
something like a can white can take and
this is just good for whites so d4 is
most likely
and now there's a very surprising move
here for light you can actually take on
e6 and if I ever do a part 2 to the 93
ceiling video I will show this line as
its Sun it's relatively new there's not
been to me like I level turning games
that's have featured this idea is white
sacks apiece on take c3 pawn take f7
King take F 7 and I think if you run
stock fish for long enough it should say
like plus point 5 for a white which is a
really nice evaluation given white is
down a piece I think the movie sock fish
recommends is just to take the pawn and
there have been some games in this
position one game that I played on me
chess I think it was a bullet game which
I did not manage to win let's go to the
Masters database
yeah the game I would recommend looking
at is the one from 2017 actually played
the same tournament where this game took
place and I was just like walking
through the the playing hall and I I was
walking through as I saw this position
on board and I realized that oh man
someone someone else discovered my
opening preparation so we'll insert the
aim and well I played nice slates it
converts but all that people actually
look through this if you want to look
deep you're deeper on your own I'm gonna
go ahead and share the link in the a
study in case people want to clone it or
anything um anyway let me show one more
line and then I'll be done after pawn
take East six black might not be too
motivated to go into this piece a Cline
so black could very likely take back on
musics and then there's just a cool
sequence of moves for white White's not
gonna move the knight but continued
counter-attacking
I can play queen h5 e six mean II five
acting the rook
I think the only move for black is to
play Queen ah six and then Queen c7
backing the bishop black still can't
take the Knights back has three choices
all these Queen moves let's say what's
at Queen g7y can trade Queens and
finally move the knight and all of this
was just a trade we get in this look
into some like positional middle game
where it is equal material but White has
like a number of rich plans a lot of
which focus on kind of exploiting either
the e6 pawn or the e6 square so for
example like Bishop h3 bringing the
Knight to g5 there's all these potential
pawn breaks on the Queen side to like
like a four even b4 to try and undermine
blacks kind of overextended pawns so
it's a fun position and I would usually
be happier playing this from the white
side so anyway I hope that gives people
some inspiration
I can't really stay much longer because
I have other commitments today and I
think what I'll do I'll just scroll up
in the chat cuz I wasn't really looking
earlier chat where are you
mm-hm
okay
clickbait I mean yeah maybe it's click
baits I am okay I for those of you who
just joined I'm in the classic chess
studio people who watched chess online
would actually recognize where I am and
in in about two hours I'll be doing
commentary for the summer chess classic
which is taking place in st. Louis and
the games are going on right now so the
commentary starts to a half hours after
the round starts
so I would encourage people to watch
that's if if you want to see more of me
you're not sick of me already I'll be
doing commentary with Catarina and Silva
but I'm gonna end the stream here and
[Music]
before I go let me raid someone
I wanted to do it where I would like
raid the st. Louis chess club twitch
channel I don't know if the broadcast is
gonna be on twitch it might be and I do
all the host fun so you might be able to
like go to their channel later and see
me but I get to the homepage and pause
the tournaments
go to streamers people are screaming
[Music]
I actually don't know too many of these
people I know King crusher let's click
on the last one raid zoom pili
okay
I'm me unmute this
the English
is a seamless
wait who's oom pili
this guy looks interesting is an Aussie
accent six viewers okay we're rating
this guy a snatch Pato raids match Pato
and yeah please try and watch later it's
it's new for me doing commentary in like
a studio but hopefully it'll be
instructive and I will see you guys in
the future